哇 今天台灣股市又大跌了
一度跌千點
最後跌大概五六百點 五百多點
很多人想要知道台灣股市三大重點
第一個 結算進轉折嗎?
這一句話是我發明的喔
指責發明的喔
什麼台股得了博彩的病
這都是我發明的喔
很多人拿去引用 沒有關係
可是我要重申一次 這是我的專利
結算進轉折
會不會這一次轉折是晚上還是晚上
因為今天結算日嗎?
最新的期貨
衛平山的多單還是空單
是怎麼一回事
應該是空單啦
怎麼一回事
台股萬點目標不變嗎
今天重點要跟大家講
第二個 債券直率標深
這個是非常專業的
今天頭版新聞才有人講到
講了以後你能看到
很多分醫師 很多財經管理在講
昨天之前我覺得已經在重生這個東西了
那會不會進到海嘯重演
因為20年來一個新高
上次就是賽卷直率應該說利率的飆升
戳破這一切
那會不會 AI 泡沫戳破
這很重要
第二個 第三個 我今天反逆勢加碼這檔股票
那這代表 AI 沒有泡沫嗎
戳我買的是不是 AI 的股票
今天所有的秘密我一次講個夠
大家好 我是莫爾沃特顧的頭長
郭總的醫師
今天剛好主持人請假沒有關係
那哲哲我今天來跟大家講
來講一個台股的秘密
為什麼都台股的秘密 我們來看一下
來看一下 今天台灣股市跌589點
怎麼看 其實我一直要講結算鍵轉折
今天你們冷靜一下好不好
台灣股市漲了7000點 不可能每天漲
那你會不會打第二隻腳
但你不能說戰爭船第二隻腳
第二隻腳定義我覺得至少要回到
比如說4萬2 打到4萬2在這邊
雖然會有這船團腳
我覺得真的更嚴厲一點是應該再回到4萬點
我覺得再回到4萬點的機率蠻低的
為什麼蠻低?我先跟大家講來
第一個我們來看一下
台灣有點被廢半給拖累
我們請大家請那個威漢來給我看一下
今年廢半指數的斬跌幅
我們來看今年廢半指數斬跌幅
還有那個廢半
納斯達克
還有那個SMP500
日本韓國 台灣股市這6個
請他告訴我數字要
你要問AI也可以
請我要馬上告訴我
為什麼要請他做這個圖
我告訴你就是
今年美國股市並沒有上漲很多
台灣股市大概上漲53%
從年初到現在
非辦指數沒有
如果印象沒出來
1 20%而已
那是拿個1 20%
好不好 很簡單
因為我說
我有買這種國外的ETF
或者0062這種是不是納斯拉克ETF
所以算一下報酬率大概知道了
好不好
10幾%而已
頂多10幾%
所以這些
那為什麼
10幾%要幹嘛
我想重點
美國股市不太存在有一個崩盤的空間
因為今年它展的還真的不多
美國股市沒有存在崩盤空間,因為今年長得不多,整個邏輯怪怪的,因為長不多所以就一定不會崩嗎?
但是景氣崩盤也會崩,只是就一個中財型來看的話,你每年大概是長120%,今年真的長不多啦,這幾年還長更多,今年長更多到2、30%
所以那是拉克今天展不多,費辦也不展不多,所以理論上這兩個指數跟台灣相關系數最重要的兩個股市
基本上不破底,台灣股市破底的機率就不會大幅度增加,這我給你獨家祕密
我想趕快給我那個數字,好嗎?
我跟大家講
所以來,我們今天來今天點點名
因為網友們每次都很現實
大跌都傳遣到我,對
接萬計了,來
今天我剛好今天是情人節
不過我送大家一個禮物
我拿一下
愛心
好了,人笑話
其實大家有情人
有情人終成眷屬
這剛好符合時時
而且很多時候我遇到在前面
我是不是說過
我說你發現到 不論是你要跟男生分手
還是男生要跟女生分手
人家以前會報復你
到最後會報復你 不論成性也好
久妹的女朋友也好 會報復你怎麼樣
心委屈的 心真的很委屈
錢也委屈的
你不能人家錢跟心都委屈
你讓人家人才兩死
你就很容易變成報復
所以有時候錢能解決很多的事情
錢不一定讓你一定幸福沒滿
但沒有錢會很容易讓你非常不開心
所以祝大家有錢人、有情人、中全建築
你的愛心跟鈔票一線之隔
記得這是人生後黑血
好不好 我會送大家一個花
花在哪裡 卡住了 花在這邊
好不好 蛋梗
愛你們啦 哲愛你們好不好
不要再叫哲哲寶貝了 這我都害羞了
好不好 看一下
來來來
還有人說哲哲
你那個喜歡男生女生
我告訴大家
只要你們喜歡我
你們愛我
我都愛你們好不好
這個有點
哲哲
十八鏡喔
我是不太
幫人家煮麵
所以很多人說
哇我一定很溫柔
跟別人比較
不要亂講
可是我很大方
我很大方
我是屬於那一種
就是譬如說你去名牌店
譬如說去Dio或去哪邊
可能本來要買我的
對家人、對你所愛的人
可能自己本來要買
可能自己都沒有買
然後可能別人身上花個幾十萬
我就是這種人
你就買一買我也不想買
好不好
所以還算大方了
應該算大方了
好不好
那應該是車圓的
我也不知道自我介紹
來
所以我覺得其實哲哲的那個私生活不重要啦
重點是投資的品德
同資的品性你們可以高規格要求我
這個我絕對沒問題啦
這個我經得起挑戰
好不好
短期美在可以買嗎
美在同農事垃圾
好不好
只有我留著垃圾
哲哲寶貝今天剪的國劇好華麩店
華麩店我有一點想買到華麩店
你實在長有點多
國劇我今天就是剪的國劇
怎麼剪的啊可以講
好不好
好不好 車寶貝
不好意思 很有愛又大凡 謝謝你們
好不好 這跟大家講
好不好 半夜四點報股票
去年不會要什麼東西 好不好
來來來 航運股最近有久
航運股最近很猛
你看我不要去講那些
你有沒有看到一些老頭戶也好
其他航運股強的 開始就說我有航運股了
他已經忘記你的AI股了
他已經忘記你的記憶體了
他忘記你的南亞科 忘記你的群聯
萬晉的爬班店 萬晉你的老AI管達
萬晉你的矽關子、CPO 萬晉的被動元件
就突然有航運股了
又不是每個人都一來一去的
所以我覺得不要做這種事情
航運股我一看 但是有些我現在還是出在AI
因為航運股長不會長太多
只有AI股才是完蛋 好不好
這跟大家講
貴情人節快樂
謝謝你們每個教寶貝
好不好
怎麼看目前的惠利趨勢
慕尼文利攤台幣有回升了有回升了
我們今天我們要講很多總經典
慢慢講好不好
我講到你們會覺得
要不是我
我們先講說美在這個垃圾
要不是我當分析師
我真是少賺一億啊我會騙你
我是說真的啦
你們都知道我
我再講一件事情
我在1萬7的時候
我本來要出掉
是因為有人叫我不要
大家有人罵我,我就沒有出了
大家都知道
我是今年買台灣50在這邊買對不對
沒錯吧
往大印象
去年買台灣50在這邊
沒有錯,這邊喔
你們看錯沒
你們看錯
今年台灣50在這邊嘛對不對
去年台灣50在這邊
沒有看錯,這邊
這邊
不清楚 直接看 現在4萬4
去年台灣50買這邊
什麼時候買這邊
18000多 這個玩路上都有消息都有報導
那時候我就想要把美
所以那時候為什麼是用湊錢去買台灣50
因為那時候美債沒有賣掉 被卡住了
是不是 你看那時候如果放到現在台灣50
1.7億美債都賣掉 換台灣50不長很多
不會是現在這樣子
虧錢情況之下
我兩隻夾起來好像差不多
因為我一次賺1500萬
現在就是虧錢販子
好啦
所以我說美債就不要買了
好不好
美債目前除非你資金就是一億以上
你要部分的飯
好 為什麼說美債是個垃圾
我罵自己可以罵
不是罵大家
我還持有這個垃圾
你看美債規模
2027年看到
從9點多債有沒有看到
你看到現在2026年看到
我們看這邊
這是2026
這每一點都是一年一年了
你看喔
現在38.51到39
你看
今年你看喔
前幾年才
2020年才23兆
現在已經38兆
2020年才多少
無限QE那一年才23兆左右
有沒有到
從23兆到27兆
現在38兆了
那去年38兆
現在要突破40兆了
有沒有到
前幾年才31兆而已,2022年AR寒勤的時候,
現在又增加10兆了,你看2027年的時候,
金融海峽才10兆的規模,現在已經變40兆了,
所以錢越來越不值錢了,所以我才說傻瓜才把錢放在銀行,
銀行定存永遠給你定存利率1.2%
可是你看現在30年期關在直立率你看多高了
是不是在這邊你自己看
來來來到5.33
銀行就拿你的錢對不對
哇你買1億你把1億的錢放在銀行傻瓜
定存2%啦,不到啦,不到喔,去買美國公債啦,5%以上啦,人家什麼都沒做就賺你300萬啦,最少把錢放在銀行,而且從發債規模你看2007年那時候金融海峽20年前而已,不到10兆,
你現在沒有幾年的時間就增加10兆美金
這代表什麼意思?
發債規模越來越快
代表政府一再贏鈔票
代表錢越來越不值錢
錢越來越不值錢啊各位
所以這是資本主義的必然趨勢
這也是
因為你很多人不懂歷史
所有的高層管理階層就是逼大家怎麼樣
不斷的往前進不斷的工作
工作的兩個好處,第一個讓自己頭腦健康,身體健康,
這是我一直秉性的,你們不認同沒關係,
可是第二個你也不得不工作,因為錢會越來越薄,
如果錢越來越肥,通縮不好意思,那沒有人要工作,
你懂這個陰謀論,這真的是合理的陰謀論,
資本主義市場就是一直不斷的通膨,把你的錢給吃掉,
能不能把你的錢給吃掉,所以你要別錢給吃掉,
你就要像鐵銅裡面的老鼠,你要跑得更快,
最好的投資是股市,要聽懂我這句話,
而且不要愛啊,這世界不公平,不要去怨恬有人,
我就先講,很多人講AA制AA制,
我說哪個美女的追求者會給她AA制,不會啊,
因為知道別的競爭者一定是花錢在他身上
能不能?
男人何苦為難男人?
能沒有辦法?
能不能?
你不AA字,你要跟他勾大群
跟他各付各的,不好意思
美女不理你
我要找個理想對象,不好意思
這個不存在
你懂嗎?
那可能他個性溫柔
很好
但是他各方面條件都非常好
很難
能不能?
很多人都理想主義者
這世界上沒有一個完美的理想主義
你什麼都不要計較
你反而算比較多
來,有時候講講愛奇流,就講講股市
這個東西要借邏輯,好不好
每載子力那麼高,你看那靠今年以來30年起公佔
因為規模越滾越大,拉起來了,42 BP
就是大概就是一個百分點,0.01
增加0.42%,30年起美國公佔
2007年以來的新高
我們來看一下
5年期公債也增加很多啦
10年期公債也增加很多好不好
就比例而言10年期公債增加比較快
因為同樣都是大概52Bp
大概就是0.52%
就是大概0.5%左右
Base比較小的
基準比較小的是不是增加比較多
等等
這邊有比較枯燥沒關係
我快速跟大家講好不好
你去看一下在昨天之前有沒有跟你講
說美債常常值利率飆升
有沒有人跟你講這個
昨天有沒有人跟你講說
30年的美債飆售利率創25年新高
你只要講這件事情
來我們看一下公安時報的頭版
我們看公安時報的頭版
你相信我你看了所有財經管好
開始會講這個東西
有本事就早點講啊
各位
為什麼我最早講
因為我是美債垃圾的專家
1.71
現在0098A有沒有 你知道為什麼
納克賣掉只剩一張
一張要觀察一下 你知道嗎
你有美在 你每在
你有持股就算剩一張你就會觀察它
所以我對美在呀 直立我特別敏感
不過啦 我跟大家講我是覺得
人生開心就好 真的人生開心
雖然嘴巴唸唸唸 我完全不後悔
對不起 哲哲剛好有個不專業的地方
謝謝威漢有給我做這個東西
我說錯了,對不起我剛剛一段話說錯
是納斯達克只有33%,我是買納斯達克的ETF
沒錯吧,可是廢半有69%
可是納斯達克不太存在有暴跌的空間
你知道嗎?OK嗎?
這沒錯吧,美股也沒有啊,沒錯吧
所以我剛才講一半對
美股大部分的美股沒有存在暴跌的空間
請威漢把這張圖趕快簡化,叫AI做一下
天賭嗎?
那梅谷裡面的納斯達克長很多,但梅谷裡面的廢半
跟什麼?
廢半指數跟SMP500指數
長不多
OK嗎?
那通常而言,台灣股市是納斯達克指數的漲幅
再加費半指數的產幅的中間值記起來
中間值大概是現在差不多82差不多
台灣股市在產54差不多差不多
真的 這個我是獨家跟你講的
台灣股市的產幅通常是費半
比如說費半我今天產6%
然後我納斯達哥產2%是6加28
8出又是4%
所以台灣股市應該要產個4%
在能不能懂?understand
有沒有分析師跟你講這些
沒有
你不要看著真美,那個可以講一些愛情的笑話
什麼愛情的梗
沒有,我們真的厲害是頭腦好不好
真的啦,我跟你講你如果網紅看起來很專業
那些都是人家研究員給他資料,腦袋裡面
裡面懂不懂?
你懂不懂?
欸,頭髮你要搞清楚喔
有些人是寫,不是我的臭屁
我不要攻擊,我跟你講你就是現象喔
有些人是寫文章,寫文章我會先查AI資料
可以了,可是你看我都看著你眼睛講
有些人是錄音,沒有我看人家講你怎麼知道他們怎麼搞,一堆搞念子
因為我都在我腦海裡,你們問我問題我直接回答
各位寶貝們,我說的沒錯吧,你要知道我跟別人差別
然後改開放直播問你們,問我,你懂不懂,美在這個東西你看
不是美在,這個直立的東西這幾天一定有很多人講
頭版新聞就這個,官方直播頭版新聞
那今天開始很多網紅在講的,為什麼不像我提早講
這的確是一個大問題,我一直跟大家講
今年我最怕什麼?我不怕AI泡沫
我只怕,我只怕直率問題,我只怕升息問題
有沒有講,升息不就載菌直率會飆高了嗎?
是不是,我只怕升息,因為2022年就從18000-120002
就是一直升息一直升息一直升息,為什麼?
升息很簡單,你升息完以後,我用一個簡單
我這樣可以用折線率的功夫,比較專業的說法
我怕你聽不懂
我用一個最簡單的東西好了
如果我台灣股市的平均值率百分之三 percent
對不對
我公債值率率也三 percent
可是我台灣因為台灣股票一直漲
值率會下滑變兩 percent
台灣股市值率變兩 percent 假設
可是我公債值率從三 percent變六 percent
你資金會不會去買公債
會嘛 六 percent 股市兩 percent
雖然股市有成產性 可是多少有些資金會來
來到債市 所以資金會吸到這邊去
會吸到債市 就是這樣子崩盤
這樣子 原本都3% 可是股市因為漲變直率
變2% 直率就是我100萬我可以賺2%
ok嗎 好 我先不管成產性
我管他的股利 股利就好
然後公債 因為一直印鈔票
我印鈔票也要怎麼樣?我要吸引你高利率
你知道嗎?以前的這樣子啊
好不好?以前是老鼠會的這樣子
哇!給你高利率變6%
當然美國債券不會是老鼠會
絕對不會倒啦
變6%
美國債券變6%你會不會資金從股市移過去?
一個2%、一個6%差很多
越差越多
這邊7%、這邊8%等我意思吧
資金的吸引來吸引去
來 昨天只有我講這一個
我說30年標授美在直立率穿25年新高
應該不是20年應該說25年新高 標授利率
5.216 標授利率
沒關係 這個有點
我講太多我怕你們聽不懂 好不好
反正我講過直立率問題
來 阿發貝茲是6.4有沒有人呢
是不是
那現在很文,因為AI的關係你能不能懂
AI我缺錢,我公司付得起6%是7%
所以6%7%我來,像這樣子喔
沒有分析就跟你講這麼簡單
就是我因為AI投資的關係
你們說我現金有問題嘛,好我去借錢
我借錢我一定要高利貸嘛
是不是,因為越借越多
我借100萬的利率跟1000萬的利率一定不一樣
借那麼多你一定要借那麼多
那你利率要給我多一點
有時候我尊重講這段 有講這一段
AI利率越接越多
然後它的公司債人力利率會飆高
條件一定要飆高你才會借我
越飆越高
飆到6%以上
那美債值利率
這時候的畫面給我
AI的公司債 AI公司就是阿發貝斯Google
他們的公司債越飆越高
變6.4%甚至7%以上
6%至7%
那是不是資金會往AI走?
往AI走沒錯吧
那這時候我美國再見怎麼辦?
我也缺錢啊
前幾年才30兆 現在快40兆了
那我也缺錢怎麼辦?
我前輩你洗手了
那我也要飆高
我一起飆高音
是不是? 參一下小安
我要飆高音
是不是? 要飆高音
大家飆高囉
公在飆受利率要飆高
你看我前輩AI公司搶走了
美國政府要發行美國公債
我也要標高
從4%多變5%
被AI公司搶走
美國的公債也要標高
美國公債標高那是股市又遭殃
那麼多一個循環
昨天有沒有跟你講
這些有 OK嗎
發債規模的
投資型公司之類好不好
0.4兆是還好,但也不小
你要看一件事,去年才1.1兆
現在一下子增加0.4兆,增加4000億美金
連增36%很誇張
最後講這一段
是不是
來,關鍵數據
2007年
可是我今天標題很手動
我這個一件事,歷史會重演
那我在這邊可以賣個彎指好不好
要不要先休息一下
這段有點複雜好不好
會不會太難
太難我不要講了
來看一下
有聽到嗎
不要高音
突然要不要高音
不然無聊
我們在會不會太複雜
我怕太複雜的時候
我先跟你講我今天
唯一買進那檔股票
國巨我們念一下
那個一一報念一下
8月19號禮拜三今天的簡訊
已經買進2327國巨掛在570元買進
已經買進的不用再買
國巨也買了有沒有
現在576啊
所以買得漂亮
好不好 買得漂亮
我覺得很難回到500元以下
因為做做第二支腳
理論上不存在
好不好
不存在的腳
OK嗎
不太會破底
好不好 OK
而且很多你看6173新餐店暫停版的各位
很多備份員竟然是長2492華興科怎麼樣
是不是還是長了
現在大部分很多敢拉股票的地方記住
處置跟以前差很多了
本來20分鐘一次處置最多
現在被2分鐘一次處置了差很多
這力多還是會持續發酵
好 我們剛才講的為什麼歷史不會重演來看
它現在長短在利率差沒有很多,你懂不懂
所以現在問題是美國,它30年期每在指利率有沒有看到
它不太一樣,那個30年期每在指利率
它是我要升息,我要升息,你會看到兩個,費的利率有沒有看到
現在費的利率大概差不多3.75左右,跟美國公債的利率不一樣
來 再講一次 這個他畫的 你們看到
紅色是30年起美在紫綠 藍色是廢的綠綠
我這樣圖表很好 我做得很好 我為他做得很好
歷史說怎麼不會重演 真正會戳破
我跟你講 真正會戳破的話
我們問的是廢的綠綠 不是美在紫綠綠
可是因為現在有人看到陰影就打槍
看到黑影就設,很多網紅、很多華爾街的分機師
那現在台灣的一些網紅,我曾經分
其實台灣的網紅有些總經鏈
比台灣的一些本土分機師還厚實,我得要說
他們反而注重總經鏈,我得要說
可是最厲害的總經鏈是我
來,我看他們的結論這樣子
因為他們會出破泡沫的
永遠都是廢的生息
這記者一件事,會出破真正泡沫
網路泡沫也如此
2008年金融海嘯也如此,都是做個籌碼面去戳破,
拜託你把這一段記起來,一百倍一定要記起來,
好,所以那時候他們就挖戳破2007年的一個反地產泡沫,
到2008年金融海嘯,就是因為美在直率很高,
慘了,我們現在的直率比2007年的直率還高,是不是美在直率,
錯了 為什麼錯了?
那是因為我以前說如果費的利率在5.25
你每在值利率你能比它低嗎?
我的基準就在這邊了
我發行公債利率當然比它高一點
但是我的基準就在這邊了
我費的利率 現在費的利率像美國央行一樣
台灣央行一樣 費的利率就是像台灣的央行
我基準利率在這邊 我要發債那是比它更高
沒錯吧,我這個利率就在這邊,就5.25,我一定比它高
聽楚邏輯
所以那時候戳破它,泡沫是費得利率
因為那時候費得利率就那麼高了,2017年
所以每在值得利率也那麼高
可是現在每在值得利率5.31,看起來很高
但實際上,費得利率這麼低,FED利率那麼低
像台灣央行的美國央行,講美國央行,
反正就這樣講你會比較聽懂,
的利率這麼低,
這樣懂嗎?
以前是因為有這件事,你不能用這個東西來看,
你不能用美在職業來看,
真正撮破泡沫的是什麼?
是廢的利率,
那為什麼現在誤差那麼大?
因為發災規模越來越大,
發在規模越來越大,還有AI,就我講的AI洗走的美在的一些資金
還有它不得不提高,多少會影響一點點的,但真正戳破泡沫是費得利率
那懂不懂,以前為什麼費得利率那麼高?
因為我原本費,以前為什麼美在利率那麼高?
因為我費得利率就那麼高,所以我不得不高
那現在為什麼費得利率這麼低,美在利率這麼高?
因為發在規模越來越高了,好不好?
理論上不會泡沫,可是一定會吸收一些資金
還是會有一些流動性的問題,你懂不懂?
菇子還是會下修,OK嗎?
OK嗎?有些錢還是會借錢來?
我又借錢不好意思,你要我借你錢
結果你說拜託一點可不可以4%利率?
我賺4%利率不如去買美國公債
所以借錢會有問題,還是有一點?
這還是有問題,只是不會像費得綠到5%的時候或是全面性的,
這樣懂不懂?這邊有點專業了,我就不講太多了,
我怕你們聽不懂,你們看一下,想看你自己看,
好不好,這真的很專業了,
可是這個籌碼面的確是個問題,好不好,
我們看有沒有東西,來,
還有這個就是講的,利率如何壓縮AI估值,
為什麼很簡單,就是我利率善生,我責限就會變低,講這個太複雜了,
我不管你們不要聽的,反正就是一個東西可以到5%,我借錢可以到5%了,
股票市場就沒那麼漂亮了,就這樣子,所以錢會完再試走,
OK吧,知道嗎?知道我邏輯,太專業,我怕你們聽不懂,
好吧,每這個寶本你真的寶本而已
好不好,不你在怎麼樣還是比
不,美在不能說是樂事
那定準還是樂事,我想起來
好,OK嗎?
OK,好不好,明年會準成像這樣
很難講這個要不要持續發酵
請問我把紅磊換成華班甸你會推薦嗎?
我覺得不錯,但是因為你就是賭一把
可是華班甸的問題就是漲很多
你懂不懂這事啊?
我幫你長很多,你懂不懂嗎?
其實我還是蠻看好他的啦
我覺得如果到150以下我會真的用
我150以下我買的機率很高
不代表現在不買,好不好?
就決定你勝負的成本你記得這件事
決定你勝負的成本
為什麼現在還講到那麼大聲
台灣50我喜歡賺一千多萬
為什麼講到那麼大聲
因為台灣50賺一千多萬
你懂不懂嗎?
這就決定我的勝負,OK嗎?
來,定時還是垃圾,真的真的
你要顯示美國美在規模越來越大的時候
為什麼越來越大?
因為錢滾錢
錢滾錢
你知道嗎?
當你有一兆的時候
同樣每年漲10%
你有一兆的時候漲10%
跟有10兆的時候漲10%
哪個漲比較快?
一定10兆嘛
對不對?現在規模已經要40兆美金了
你懂不懂?
來,請問一下利率高是刻意安排的揚謀
那美國富豪們持續產品賺高利息的
不是,不是,我不能這樣講
就是我覺得應該說這個你把我講得錯了
資本主義的市場或整個市場就是這樣子
它要讓人們持續的工作
因為人們都不工作怎麼辦
像不是機器人都發生
那這社會就產品的人就慘了
資產就不會流動了
所以最好的方式就是一直通膨
但太高通膨也不好
所以沒有人喜歡很高通膨
OK嗎
來
我想把三張中美金換成國具好嗎
不是會員一直問會員的問題
我不會理你們
我們來看一下
中美金也沒什麼不好
中美金這邊也可以再買
真的
太誇張了
其實都跌很凶
台灣股市之前前一波大戶受傷太嚴重了
他們現在
為什麼你知道很多人喜歡講第二隻腳
因為股市很少V1轉尤其他人會凶
所以很多人喜歡講第二隻腳會不會第二隻腳會
那會不會第二隻腳
當然有機會你看現在股票有第二隻腳
因為它反彈的弱
現在這麼反彈那麼弱的我確定你拉回都可以買
只能會破底
我覺得基地很低
我剛已經講過了美國股市漲不多
所以不要想那麼多好不好
來
台灣股市很猛
之前是韓國股市贏我們賺了80-90%
你看這些都用AI做就好
AI查出資料、AI做圖
你看前三名第一份是費辦
韓國,韓國本來長到80、90%
還是長100%
韓國股市也修正很嚴重的
然後納斯達哥跟SNP500也沒有漲很多
既然他們沒有漲很多
那你就要去想想看
沒有漲很多,他們其實破底的機率
跌到一年,跌到說0%
很難
你聽懂嗎?我今天如果我展100%
我韓國股市我展100%
我修正一半,我跌50%是很正常
我今天納斯拉克只展13%
你不要想他也多好不好
基本上我覺得美國股市
不存在泡沫空間
目前為止
AI真的是差很多
不然你們拜託一下,正常很多
想要請問你昨天提的群聯有沒有機會
有機會了,我選低機器的慢慢轉
是不是?你看群聯今天為什麼收紅K
你跟他去問今天 為什麼2408
問南亞科今天點的熊
我們請問 剛才海力士好像跌10%
好像我剛有新聞消息出來
問一下三星海力士的走勢圖
我們請一下那個危害人家好不好
來啦 2408
2408南亞科好不好
我們先3.14分 我們先休息一下好不好
先中產休息一下 我當然給你更多祕密
好不好 只要喝個水
喝水 休息一下 滿懷
我們剛才看那個之前的預告
廣告 中間廣告 可能已經減掉了 沒關係
可是你也有看到的人也看到
以前1萬3而已有沒有 2020年1萬3
以前12682歷史天閒 沒有
現在討論是不是5萬點
錢就是一直越來越薄
可是股市是看通報
什麼叫股市可以看通報
就是我每年我被我100萬塊
實際上我會變97萬
我每年3%被通報吃掉 3%到4%
實際上你的購買力道成變97萬
你只買97萬東西
電腦嘛
可是你的投資股票100萬
很容易變120萬
在看通膨
扣掉通膨後你還是可以賺個10萬、20萬
懂不懂
那臺灣的房地產現在不成看通膨
因為已經少實話了
很多人現在就等著爸爸來繼承
那怎麼辦
除非你有乾性需求
你懂不懂
我就是要買房子
自己住開心
我就是要開公司
自己住可以居住比較好
自己買比較好
不然不要買
好不好?台灣版立場應該已經注定了就是崩壞的開始
好不好?來,哲越為年輕,謝謝大家
所以我就說現在要讓大家開心一點
你說越為年輕也是要維持很多
年輕有兩種,一種是做醫美
一種是心靈善
做醫美你心情善不好還是看得出來很類你知道嗎?
其實有些真的
我一樣看有些年輕女生都整過頭
其實如果...
就知道有看過
我很厲害 我看得出來一個女生是B字
B字枕還是嘴巴打到小丑女的嘴巴
我看得出來我有對美感很厲害
整過頭都不太行
這車遠的 為什麼會想這個
好啦
來
這枕你不好幫歪了
好 來
廣告會繳解解是意義嗎 不是
一一穿衣服很保守
好 依效 非常保守
管女生
韓國拉拉很多是
韓國拉拉很多 拉拉是
來來 哲哲越南無數
好啦 京劇可能是最帥氣的哲哲京劇可以報
很多人講我看一下
在朝底一次 韓國人知道我厲害
不要啦 我每次買第一個是嗎
不要不要不要
幹嘛在朝底我不懂
又不是在跌破4萬點
跌破4萬點你只問我好不好
基本上不會跌破4萬點
剛有兩種金居是金居
像我帥氣
其實我跟你講
你不覺得一股票10個不要
你有沒有犯大
你把它撤出你不覺得有點像國劇嗎
你不覺得像中美金嗎
都是要打第二隻腳
趕快買
之前你不敢買
這邊買是漂亮
這邊買真的漂亮
你相信我好不好
金居我覺得還是有機會
但是我覺得它本來比有點過高
好不好
國劇715均價
最近有沒有可能解奏
有機會
反正我建議你這邊就不是建議你
如果你是我會演維說器500多再買
好不好
台子長的
明天要V轉了嗎
我們看到台子長多少
為什麼沒動
3.18分了
我們看一下
有有有
長140點
140點你就要長了
我跟你講你沒有感覺好不好
0.5%才有感覺
1%算正常
所以你只400多點算正常好不好
現在是4萬4千,來看一下,加你們的數字好不好,來來
這個很簡單,因為他們每個人數學不一定一樣
像台灣股市是4,4,7,1,9,沒有很簡單的數學,來來來
這個有些人會想要轉台,4,4,7,9,1%嘛對不對
去掉後面,你就把去掉後面的尾數,後面把他去掉
你要就是百分之一400,447.1%才叫做波動,稍微有波動的感覺
懂了,直接不是台灣股市跌1000多點,那3%
那你真的要有像樣的波動,一點點像波動
0.5%出於2,447出於2,223.5
那223.5才0.5%
所以這個教你減斷數學以後去掉尾數兩個
其實說一個正常波動
稍微有一點點波動
再處於2、220、3
數算法說每次看就知道這個
到底政府高不高
OK嗎?現在139點
不多啦
你看我今天教很多大家數學
我太無聊了
太無聊了
不要講那麼多
太專業不好
我一直講一件事
我覺得我是蠻自己自豪的事
你們是直接問我 我都直接講
你不論你是看到人家是用
我不是要攻擊人家,我有可能專業
可是你如果管播也好,寫文章也好
哪一個像我這樣直播,你當然信問我
我可以講很多東西
而且我很多資訊都是比華爾街領先
你真的是外行看得讓內行看門道
我是跟你說真的好不好
OK嗎?我們看到是頭腦啦,真的啦,好不好
頭腦很重要,所以這個行情在之前那時候
台灣股市最大問題就是生...被搶走的事情
現在公在持率率有點高、有點危險
如果連費的利率也提高了
那就很危險
對不對
OK嗎
這跟大家
可是股市就在半信半應中成長
股市在半信中成長
好不好
OK嗎
好
來拉回答第二支橋趕快買好不好
下半年
我要五萬點
五萬點我講的是至少
我認為至少
投資本資料盡工參考
沒有一定
我們是合法分析師
OK嗎
來
只是我看法是覺得蠻有機會的
好吧 管達 管達怎麼看管達
這線情不錯
其實我是覺得紅瀾木我們奇妙了
不應該這樣疊 神經那給我這樣疊的就是
很不給面子
代表這CEO不行
CEO 這個講話要爽動一點
你沒有學到市場上的講話
當CEO要做很多事要會行銷你知道
來,那我們來看一下,這成員的
來,5483中美金的一樣,
那黃金金怎麼看?
來,黃金金金的昨天快斬停,
今天一下快跌停,神經病,
就跟精彩一樣,前天跌停怎麼樣?
昨天給你斬停,前天跌停,
昨天給你一度拉拉斬停,
今天又給你殺下去,神經病,
但是部分是國際股市關係,
所以現在股票不追高,
再點是現在股票不追高,
相反拉回買進,拉回買進做加差
你跟女公用國際700多塊,奇怪你逢地又怎麼買
你逢高到600多塊就可以先走了,你拉回做企貪就好了
有1200的人很多人說哲哲我1200的國際
就不回來啦,我是不好意思跟你講啦
你沒有逢地貪品你就不回來啦
不是那不是每一檔股票都可以逢地貪品
我覺得國際可以逢地貪品
所以你的股票的套位高檔你什麼都不能到
那股市真的不適合你,聽懂嗎?你第一檔的時候你該加碼加碼,
但同學說什麼嗎?該加碼加碼,好不好?
這跟大家講,來來來,我們來看一下喔,
來喔,這是凡軒,我還要講什麼,請問要聊天嗎?
親人節聊天
聊一下指責的東西好了
所以有時候還是要講一個很正面的問題
有時候大家好可能不知道
為什麼我說同業
也之前我去年的時候不是同業攻擊我
一個星星講得很誇張
講得好像我跟主力配合一樣
然後還有才調動爭氣大隊
去政交所去寒
幸好我完全沒有任何
那個跟主力配合即將
他差所有的同時間
有沒有什麼人頭帳戶
我完全沒有
千劫比不起訴更證明我的清白
至少兩個警察官千劫
我說沒有 我知道你為什麼我這麼生氣
因為我真的覺得很生氣是
有時候你知道 我昨天知道為什麼
有時候有些人有些受害者
在法院的時候 到座不去法院
我每次開一支庭 我都要想像他們那時候
什麼污賴我的
之前還講到說 哇 什麼出生什麼地下期貨
我之前的公司的某些人員涉及這個事情
代表我有嗎?還寫得很清楚
在什麼散書案件即要即號
一看那裡面根本就沒有我
那個彰性分析是敢這樣寫
完全就是無賴我
該付出代價都要付出代價
該付出代價都要代價
這則我跟妳講
我買個美帳我都不在乎少賺幾千萬幾億
我花多少的綠質費我真的不在乎
我禁告同意不要做這種事情
你根本不知道子哲一例多少
為什麼我講一講要講講
因為有時候想到很生氣
有時候我說真的我甚至攔燒我生命
那你明天有些同業在網路上
啊 子哲什麼時候他就虧錢什麼虧錢
我從來沒有說過我一定讓人家賺錢
可是我可以跟你講我是最努力的分析師
真的最努力的分析師我跟大家講的
所以我已經是法院已經逐漸的證明很多清白了
我是要告訴大家 真的真的
我講一下還是某某一下
因為今天秦仁姐
我就想講一講的事情
我最愛的秦仁就是我的工作
就是你們
就是你們真的真的我沒有工作
我覺得很無聊
真的我覺得蠻好玩
但是寒情這回答你就買
你們真的很幸福
有AI這個東西
可是我告訴你
這是幸福也是不幸
因為之後我有很多人失業
好不好
我有很多人失業
我跟大家講
好不好
這是從滿面的麻煩
這 Anthropi 給他 IPO
IPO 被吸收資金
也是好玩的地方
可是我覺得會不斷不斷有一些東西
你看他現在美國一開始已經有什麼
哇 今天美國已經模仿中國
因為中國有時候
不得不承認
中國科技有時候也領先美國
像無人機這一塊也是很恐怖
美國現在也是模仿它
以前Uber 用無人機運送Uber意思
中國先用在美國用
像機器人戰鬥機器人格鬥比賽
美國開始也有
很恐怖啊
這跟大家講
所以
我們來看一下
真的是你滿幸福的
我不知道成戰中國會講的都事實
來
那我要講的是說
以後很多人被取代
你就你要趕快撐著的時候
趕快來好不好
也是歸你失業保險
事業保險不是等政府事業保險
自己投資好不好
來自己投資好不好
歡迎中美經濟一樣
細金圓還是會需求很大好不好
不好意思 有時候花了兩三分鐘
摸摸一下
可是真的很生氣好不好
來
大家都喜歡聽一些哲哲的事情
哲哲 我可以串在一下
來
看哲言行就知道
不是真正缺錢開節目了
有沒有賺都沒差啦
我弄得很開心啊
好不好
來
來 8000人了
你們真的是
來來來 大家一起講郭慕斯你好
怎麼樣 你們都犯 覺得犯罪了
覺得做錯事了 折折我 罪折我 下跌了他找我
葉龐 up 我已經跟你講了費辦
納斯達克近展13% 美國股市沒有泡沫的危機
是費辦的也沒有什麼泡沫危機 好不好
新商店產品的 我說我是以國具為中心點的
告訴你來 華興可以買 河山 河森台也可以買
新商店也可以買
那我也可以買何生糖、信餐店
就算我買也不是全部買,不夠我塞牙縫
所以你不用懷疑我,我會跟誰配合
我都買大型股了
你乾脆說我買台積電跟阻力配合
跟衛生家配合好不好
金德奇考驗,我買什麼股票金德奇考驗
這跟大家講
來,車子的保背信領
我會印怎麼看
華班電我剛才說華班電很錯
華班電我覺得它唯一的問題是
你要設停水
如果他跌下去會很快
華星哥不錯 我喜歡的
華星哥背動年金還會上去的
下年用上升
來 你們先考我速度一下給股票
優先買環境 不錯
訊息 海利是宣佈回購股票
什麼時候的新聞 來 查一下
只能什麼時候發現自己對股市有天分的
大概做股票半年後就開始都在賺錢
就認真做啦
其實我實際上大概做股票大概做了快30年
可是那時候是放定存比較久
後來這比較認真做股票的時候
就是真的有操作
也就是放一檔股票就放很久
後來真的有認真操作後
大概一年後就覺得蠻有天分的
來,不一定有天分的
其實我跟你講你就是傻傻的
你買糖溫50
傻傻的你買雞油股去分散
基本上你都贏了90%的賞物了
其他賞物沒有賺那麼錢
沒有賺錢或沒有賺那麼多錢
這其實是我送你情人節的禮物
其他賞物我們都沒有賺那麼多錢
最大的問題是他們撐不下去
所以你不要用融資你就撐得下去
第一階條件不要用融資
不要用單寵
你單寵可以
就用我可能講的名言
我沒有說賭不好
但你不能騙自己再投資
單寵就是賭
單充是賭絕對不是投資
你們不要看那些什麼
網紅那樣如果單充多少錢
都在回忽扯了啦
單充能賺錢
我跟你講殘疾投資更會賺錢
好不好
但那一定有
有些人是少數中天分中的天分
可是
當你問我你單充會不會賺錢的時候
你就不是那種人了
基本上你已經不適合了
記我邏輯
這種東西還要問我的話
好不好
來
看你買的你也買路了
隔天的展廷,我往內賺很多
整隻寶貝,你們大膽回台灣夠了沒?
還是我繼續下單
我跟你講,我沒辦法跟你講這東西
就像我那時候就知道台股會跌破4萬點
我真的不知道,你們聽懂嗎?
台股那時候會跌破4萬點,我真的不知道
你們懂我意思嗎?
可是我只知道台股跌破4萬點,我就是用你買
可是那現在你說台灣股市會不會回打
像幾分呢?
現在台灣股市會回打
我不知道會不會回打
可是我跟你講這邊下很多股票
來 大盤在這邊嘛對不對
國巨在這邊啊
中美金在這邊啊
有些回那麼深的股票可以買
因為基本上不會破這個底
我只能跟你講
這個底理論上4萬點應該不會破
不會破的機率很高
就是有四萬點不會再來的機率很高
居然四萬點不會再回來機率很高
萬般拉回就是要買
這是我跟妳的結論
下半年了
妳要記著這件事情
來 從時間走上
五窮六決七散掉
通常會發生股災
記起來
最晚最晚
記起來我是
會發生股災最晚最晚
這個也是有時間找的
沒有分析師跟妳講這個
這是我三十年的記憶
最晚最晚是89月,8月就差不多了,9月很少股災了
你說2007、2008年金融海嘯跌到11月21日,
跌到3.9萬,可是他股災是從5月開始
要發生股災通常8月差不多了,8月還沒有發生股災,
年底Safe,年底就很安全,我都告訴你時間走了
所以有時候你問我問題,約繳約絕有道理
因為我涵蓋很多 比如時間軸 記錄線型 籌碼面 AI投資 AI的規模
還有美債的發行規模 那個要很多的參數你知道嗎
今天講的有點亂 但是今天非常專業 不會亂
因為真的要操作很多東西 好不好
ok嗎 接著八九月 一盤整三百點已經講起來
已經拉起來了 好不好 要結束了 結束了
你看到現在我來給大家做生意 好不好
群年要買 群年要買 好不好
來 群年一八八 不是群年
逆轉100%抓的今天結束 基本上10點結束的好不好
不論對我做哲哲一些一些預告前面
我看我什麼股票沒講 我們應該就講股票好了
被動元件我還蠻看好的好不好
今天拉回有買被動元件
好不好 你可以買其他的
逆轉100%抓的今天晚上10點結束
頭條我最愛的就是你們
情人節沒有你們 不論男生女生沒有你們
今天也謝謝大家 雖然你們很現實
只有議題的時候 有大題的時候才看我節目
但是我還是很愛你們 我最愛的是你們
好不好
只要你們愛我 我都愛你們
逆轉一發專案
今天晚上齊人節就好
這專案
今天晚上10點結束
要不要參加都沒關係
我愛你們好不好
歡迎來下期0806的8M包
或假如來私訊我
不論
不論一切的一切
則則通通預告在前面
去想想看
你要者的分析師
也預祝各位
能夠賺大錢
齊人節快樂
我愛你們
掰掰
本公司與所推介分析之個別有價證券
無不當之財務利益關係
本節目資料僅供參考
投資人因獨立判斷
省身評估並自負投資風險